we got this new record hold uh hold that
heat with a travis and future yes sir um
this was kind of like the first time
we've heard travis since what happened
at astroworld um and i mean
definitely didn't disappoint um how long
have you been holding on to this record
um
a good little minute you know what i'm
saying good little minute a little
minute it's been a lot of
travis is like real indecisive like you
know what i'm saying but that's my real
friend right real brother real friend
like for real for us so me and his
conversations be a little different
we'll argue all kind of [ __ ] like you
know threats go back and forth
what do you threaten him over i'll beat
him up like i'ma [ __ ] you up
if you don't even put this song i'm
gonna [ __ ] you up right after you tell
me you go let me put it out i've been
going on for a whole year i will [ __ ]
you up y'all everything but i brotherly
[ __ ] that right right not the real [ __ ]
up like yo brother luke come here
do it like you know but
yeah and he didn't tell me y'all he
threatens you back yeah he's not scared
what is he i mean how does he threaten
you though
does he say hit me up yeah yeah
lebron is scary like you know what i'm
saying i feel like he probably got hands
ugh yeah probably i i feel like by the
way you can't see what [ __ ] do now
yeah they buying sets you know what that
mean no they get beat up and they go get
a train and learn how to box they buy
sets oh i see what you're saying yeah
they didn't fight his kids i see a lot
of rappers about sets now
yeah i see a lot of artists uh bosses
are doing uh mma and [ __ ] like ot
genesis
jim this is different whiz they be at
that [ __ ] maybe at that [ __ ] gym
it's totally different like where's the
wiz he's you know people buy a set and
quit and just keep enough to do wiz it's
like oh [ __ ] somebody else right no he's
committed yeah he too committed all
right where's on some other [ __ ] right
he'll hit you with that kick that muay
thai kid
just yeah it's crazy shout out i feel
like based on the way i've seen you uh
carry yourself in whatever friction
you've had with other artists i feel
like you probably have hands as well
yeah i'll [ __ ] somebody up yeah um
if i can't i'll just call them my big
brothers they gonna [ __ ] you up have you
had a to get your would you say you have
a temper
i used to it's getting better now i'm
going to say because i feel like you
know um
there's probably a a a time in every
grown-ass man's life
where we realize we got too much [ __ ] to
lose and it ain't worth it have you hit
that point yet yeah i'm definitely at
that point right now like man i got too
much money too much [ __ ] going on yeah
yeah but like a year ago i didn't give a
[ __ ] not long ago
like 12 months ago i give a [ __ ]
everybody gonna die
this is how i go what was the
what happened that that kind of
changed your
mindset man life yeah i just started
having fun every day like you know
just kind of like you know what i did
too i kind of like just
i'd literally deleted instagram off my
phone like all that [ __ ] like i ain't
mad it's a distraction right phone for
just all the [ __ ] i had going on like
between me my baby mama
beefing with people like you know i just
deleted that [ __ ] off my phone just
focus on my music me and metro just
start having fun every day like you know
just said [ __ ] it